hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video von mir
damen und herren ich sitze hier heute
nicht alleine sondern mit dem teddy und
mit jule richter gesagt ist denn das
ich habe euch bei
gesagt dass ihr mir bilder von euch zu
senden sollte dazu euer alter schreiben
sollte julia hat diese bilder ausgesucht
wird mir die bilder zeigen und ich werde
dann raten wie alt sie sind und werde
ich das schaffe bin ich gut und wenn
nicht dann bin ich trotzdem gut weil ich
bin kleiner menschen
diesmal also leute sind jetzt hier neben
mir das bild eingeblendet was ich jetzt
gerade hier sehen könnt ihr mal selber
den kommentaren mit raten das ist jetzt
natürlich ein bisschen verstört weil die
filter hat das dadurch weg der vier
junge ich würde sagen dass dieser kleine
junge zweifel
du weißt es nicht falsch ein ja ein jahr
seien ja habe ich gerade nicht bekommen
sondern ein nummer zwei freunde
sie hat schwarze haare richtig und dass
die haare hatte sie zumindest schon mal
nicht 0 ja wohl keine ahnung wie alt die
sein könnte ich würde sagen dass ich
jetzt auf jeden fall keine zwölf ist
oder so aber man kann sich ja auch oft
enttäuschen weil mädels also die
schmeckt sich auf jeden fall schon kann
man natürlich sagen das heißt ich würde
sagen die ist die 17 52 jahre
das hier ist die nächste person freunde
man sieht er hat einige pickel im
gesicht das heißt jetzt in der puppe ja
ich muss doch das beurteilen
wieso kann ich das nicht so sagen dass
das nicht schlimm ist ich habe auch
pickel du hast auch pickel jeder mensch
hat pickel das hat also da findet ihr
stück auf jeden fall würde ich sagen
dass er so denke ich keine ahnung also
er hat hier pullover an die wird sprengt
ist es nicht 0 ich würde sagen er ist 17
da das 15 14 1 13 0 17 15
das ist das leben nein die nächste
person die wir haben ist ein mädchen im
schnee und zwar würde ich sagen also sie
hat auch pullover
ich habe überhaupt kein ich habe keine
ahnung ich kann das wohl einschätzen ich
würde sagen 17 18 ja immer ein jahr das
jetzt die nächste person freunde
ich weiß nicht genau das ist jetzt
natürlich einerseits leicht weil man
sagen kann ok mit bart und ermöglicht
wahrscheinlich älter als zwanzig oder so
aber da könnte auch alles sein
ich würde sagen 25
die halt ein verdammtes jahr
ich bin derzeit am videos produzieren
hier unter schwachen werden nicht so
viel
das ist elf ja was ja die hat ja haare
elf war keine ahnung elf das kann ich
nur sagen dass sie so denke ich und ich
würde sagen 15
wie wir auf dem bild reizungen jetzt die
ein verdammtes jahr also meine damen und
herren es ist auf jeden fall ein gut
gemachtes foto sieht es aus mit den
farben und so von daher denke ich dass
sie nicht nur jahre alt ist darf das
nicht sehen ich würde sagen dass dieses
mädchen so zwischen 12 und 18 ist und
deswegen will ich mal sagen gehe ich
genau die mitte und zwar 15 richtig nein
nein das ist richtig yahoo musste doch
nicht wenn er gerade für mich
klarstellen dass hier ist die nächste
person das könnte schwierig werden
das war bei der eilig der mund ist
einfach das nicht das ist eine hase ich
würde sagen 10 69 drauf kommen können
wenn wir eine person mit filter aber
verändert
immerhin an der stelle muss ich sagen so
sehr viele freunde wir planen ja gerade
wieder das neue merchandise für den
ersten sechs es wird auf jeden fall
krass translate und das kann ich jetzt
an der stadt auch schon mal eben ganz
gut sagen wir machen diesmal nicht nur
merchandise sondern neben den fünf sagen
ich mal mit produkten auch noch zwei
produkte die wir ein bisschen die ein
bisschen teurer sind aber ein bisschen
hochwertiger und von denen auch notierte
auflagen gebe ich mich selber auch so
ein bisschen weiter entwickeln möchte
und dann werden wir das krasse sachen
machen da werde ich aber nächster zeit
mehr zu sagen
und jetzt sage ich dass diese person die
ihr jetzt eingeblendet sieht 15 ist wie
alt die 25
was ist das nächste bild ist wundervoll
kann ich mich sogar noch 114 1 13
hier haben wir wieder einen jungen
direkt sagen ja 15
ja es ist gesehen
nachher hin hier haben wir ein medien
die gerade die schlittschuhe player
freunde auf einer eisbahn wir sind im
hintergrund eingehen was hat er ein typ
denn für eine mütze auf es wird der
kontakt mit aliens also freunde sie
fertig also gerade schlittschuh auf die
schlittschuhbahn noch nicht mit null
jahren also sie selten und daher würde
ich sagen dass sie so naja da würde ich
jetzt mal sagen 16
was nimmst du mir das handy weg 15 wo
ein jahr das ist das nächste welt der
hat s t shirt oder ist also gibt es zwar
nicht mehr aber der shop ist ich würde
sagen dass dieser junge
wer ein bisschen längere haare deswegen
würde ich sagen ist ja nicht null oder
ja akzeptiert so richtig super ich will
sagen dass dieser junge 13 14 12 15 ja
ja das ist das nächste missioniert mit
der metal glaube ich anderes deutschland
stark merge alter was also hat man sie
hat ich glaube sind streben in den
haaren also ich würde sagen 17 13 13
im ernst 13 diese schmeißt du bist nicht
war vor der kamera jetzt mach ja hier
ist du wieder die nächste person die
hatten väter auch irgendwie schön der
sommer lauter reden
ich würde sagen dass dieses mädchen 15
ist falsch wie alt sie sind 14 1
ja auch immer wieder ein bild das wir da
ein bisschen schwieriger werden könnte
das ist ich finde es immer gut wenn du
dann auch bilder von dir selbst ein
reich also da wir hier die schule haben
in ihrem abendkleid würde ich sagen dass
also 69 15 15
stimmt ja auch geschrieben also das hier
ist die nächste person freunde
ich finde jetzt weiter auf jeden fall
ganz nice glaubt das ist dieser
washington weiter ich würde sagen dass
sie so große ziele
16 18 19 20
ja ich habe es richtig direkt auf dem
ersten versuch
das cleverste 16 17 18 19 13
fick dich das ist schwer
12 ja so lokal das nächste bild wie
danzig vom jungen eine kuckucksuhr
deswegen weiß ich doch schon springst ja
jetzt soll ich sagen ja 13 1
jetzt sind ja dann ist ein 15 15 17 nein
jetzt nämlich 18 11 ja man kann so
schlecht sein also auf jeden fall 0 km h
unterwegs und fährt kein auto ist
dementsprechend eventuell noch nicht 18
hatten aber eine brille der brille
kriege darf man erst sagen wenn man 40
ist von daher würde ich sagen sie hat
auch mädchen als anfänger ist sie in
cooler mensch deswegen anhand all dieser
indizien würde ich jetzt schlussfolgern
feststellen dass sieht 15 14 16 17 18
ja warum wenn sie so schwer
ich würde sagen dass diese person die
mit der brille ganz klar 14 1 15 16h
sich ja das ist doch scheiße schwer ich
hatte wird er als zwei sache das ist so
schwer dass super stopp an der stelle wo
ich jetzt leider die sorte ist wie
werden meine damen und herren an der
stelle noch mal danke warum kannst du
hier
ich habe doch gerade schon geklatscht
auf jeden fall keinen dank an jude die
hinter der kamera sagen du hast deinen
job richtig beschissen gemacht danke bei
euch wenn euch das video gefallen hat
freunde dann lass gerne mal einen daumen
hoch da und falls ihr sowas nochmal
sehen wollt dann schreibe es in die
kommentare freunde schaffen wir 50.000
daumen hoch das wärmer ultra low plätze
auf toilette
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
an der stelle wird dann jetzt auch mal
enden
das was jetzt hier vom bio das was jetzt
hier vom video hier können jetzt
jemanden kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten meinen job ausschenken jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und wenn
ihr schon abonnent seid könnt ihr auch
die glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]